do you have what it takes
you can't outrun destiny just because
you're terrified of it it's coming
I can't do this without you
no matter what you choose
we'll come out bloody
welcome back everyone it's Charlie there
was just a big comic-con panel in London
earlier today where they showed off a
bunch of new Witcher footage so I'll
break that down really good news too we
also have a much better lock on what the
actual release date for the series is
going to be so if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Witcher videos I'll be doing episode
videos and Easter eggs when it gets here
we'll find some cool Witcher themed
giveaway to do for a merch or something
for The Witcher episode videos that I'll
do so at London MCM Comic Con they've
screened a couple new Witcher clips that
they have not released publicly yet so
the first clip shows yennefer eulogizing
a dead baby we know she'll try to save
the baby and her mother a queen Kahless
of lario that she's been travelling with
that's what this scene from the last
trailer is for with all these dead
bodies in the circle around this wagon
they've been traveling in a wagon
together they get attacked by an unknown
mage we see them teleport across a bunch
of different destinations but yennefer
is unsuccessful in evading the sorcerer
it's actually what this fight is here
with her in this desert looking
background behind her she's fighting the
mage that's coming for Queen Kahless and
her baby
all of yennefer efforts are in vain is
both Queen Kayla and her baby don't
survive the encounter then in the sky a
bird starts circling around the two of
them the two sorcerers as they're having
their gunslinger standoff moment in the
scene cuts to yennefer sitting at a
beach wearing her black outfit with her
hair all messed up from the fight as the
camera cuts to the actual dead baby
itself she looks up at the bird and says
which one of us are you here for she
starts speaking to the baby and says I'm
sorry you didn't have a life but truth
be told you're not missing much the
camera cuts back to yennefer I know it's
easy for me to say with warm breath in
my lungs and you with nothing still what
would you have had parents well they're
the ones who wrote your last act so not
much lost their friends most likely
Fairweather lovers fun for a bit I'll
admit but will eventually disappoint if
you haven't played the games or read the
books I'll explain why yennefer seemed
so pessimistic about life itself some
music starts softly playing and then she
goes on to say and let's face it you're
a girl your mother was right about one
thing were just vessels and even when
we're told were special as I was as you
would have been we're still just vessels
for them to take in take until we're
empty and alone so count yourself lucky
you cheated the game and won without
even knowing it
sleep well the music swells up and then
she starts to bury the baby in the scene
cuts out to another scene completely
different scene of serie meeting a
character named ara who's not a book
character this scene comes before Siri
winds up with the dryads in bra Kalon
after she's trying to escape sintra so
the timeline of the books is gonna be a
little bit different from the timeline
of the show because they condensed a
bunch of stuff the way the fray Alan
described this character at the Comic
Con panel because he's not an original
book characters that he's this main
source for her different perspective and
viewpoint and vital to keeping her going
early on they make a good team but
they're from completely different
backgrounds and it just meant to sort of
get her ready for her encounter with
Geralt because they're also kind of at
odds when they first run into each other
until Geralt realizes how important she
is so they using it as a way to
introduce nan book readers to ciri
because you learn a lot more about her
character during these scenes what her
personality is like before you get all
the Geralt scenes so that when they're
together and when she's with the dryads
you don't spend all this extra time
explaining who her character is but it
picks up with ciri in the snowy forest
scene here we actually seen shots of
this that they've released recently
she's looking all battered with visible
scratches on her face dirty hair the
music's playing behind her she
approaches a bush of berries holding out
a hand to pick one something gets thrown
at her hand and she picks up a stick in
gaps who's there then the dark character
appears from behind a tree he's wearing
a coat and a hat
stop right there he says he motions for
her not to eat the berries
she says you mean they're poison then
daraa signals for her to follow and we
see a rat ciri is still holding the
stick she says oh no thank you
I don't eat rat Dara shrugs as if to
leave she says wait don't go the scene
cuts to a shot of a fire with a roasted
wrath and Dara eating it ciri asks him
where in sintra did you live where are
your parents
why don't you talk I haven't spoken to
anyone in three days guess we're all on
the run I'm supposed to be going towards
someone but instead I'm running from
someone else he has this this big bird
on his head I don't even know what he
wants from me we should smother the fire
I can't be caught by him I can't
Dara offers her what's left of the rat
ciri accepts cut too
wandering through the woods there
freezing Siri gives Dora one of her
gloves then sees a flag she says look
it's a Centron flag come on were saved
then series starts running towards the
flag when she turns to check on Dora the
boy is gone completely
she asks rat-boy where did you go then
we cut to a shot of the next scene right
after this of jet-skier singing this
will scene of siri trying to escape
something she talks about two men that
she's trying to get away from is
probably from sword of Destiny when
she's actually trying to escape an
arranged marriage she takes off out of
sintra and winds up in the force -
bracha lan where the dryads live and
that's how she winds up running into
Geralt for the first time all this
footage of her talking to the dryads
here that's from that moment there where
she's forced to choose between a life
with Geralt or a life with the dryads
because the Dryas want her for her
secret power - because she has the elder
blood they recognize how special she is
this is also around the time where Gayle
realizes that she's the child of
surprise of Dooney in pavetta her two
parents Dooney actually shows up in the
trailer he's the one with a head that
looks kind of like a hedgehog and all
these big fight scenes in the throne
room in sintra so these might be in
flashbacks is not really clear how
they're gonna deal with flashbacks or
how linear the story is going to be told
because a lot of the material from the
last wish in sword of Destiny the first
two books of short stories that season 1
is going to borrow from take place in a
bunch of different times that they jump
around in time as Geralt is remembering
these events also really cool at the
convention they had this installation
with one of the monsters that shows up
during the trailer we got a little more
information about it it's actually a key
Kimura which is from the game itself
it's basically a giant spider with a
human-like looking head they each to
have this social structure amongst them
you find a lot of them in the swamps
which is why you see Geralt fighting one
in a swamp during the trailer the scene
of yennefer also kind of tees up the
idea that she and Geralt eventually
become the mother and father figures to
ciri she eventually gives all of her
motherly love to ciri once they're all
together part of yennefer sacrifice and
becoming a sorceress attaining that
power is becoming barren but also Geralt
in taking all of his witcher potions
becoming a witcher originally made him
barren too so neither one of them can
actually have children themselves so
serious ort of their adoptive child we
also haven't gotten any scenes of
yennefer actually meeting Geralt for the
first time but they
did say that they would sort of come
together on parallel storylines by the
end of the first season that's the story
of the last wish it actually involves a
genie of all things you have to imagine
that there's all kinds of different
magical creatures in the world of The
Witcher books dandelion and Geralt are
fishing dandelion pulls a jar out of the
stream realizes there's a genie in it
and unwittingly releases it the genie
attacks him Geralt goes to the nearest
town to get help for him and yennefer
just happens to be there she agrees to
help them but decides that she wants the
genies wish for herself while she's busy
fighting the genie trying to contain him
the town starts being destroyed Geralt
realizes the genies too powerful for her
goes to help her and tries to persuade
her to let it go because she wants his
wish so badly but then Geralt realizes
that he's holding the jar to seal the
genie and knows that he's the one really
controlling him so he uses his final
wish to save yennefer and bind their
fates together forever
so the title of the book in the short
story the last wish is the story of how
their fates became intertwined he uses
the genies last wish to save her since
we haven't seen the episodes yet we
don't know exactly how faithful these
moments are going to be to the book
moments but the showrunner did say that
they sort of rearranged a couple things
to make the story a little more linear
and easier to follow because like I said
most of these early short stories just
jump around all over the place and time
and aren't really that connected as for
the actual release date there was a
contest at MCM comic-con in a banner
that seemingly confirmed the leak from
earlier this year earlier this year at
the Netflix Netherlands Twitter account
accidentally posted the release date of
a bunch of different titles in December
it listed The Witcher was coming out the
week of December 17th the week right
before Christmas but then Netflix came
out and said no no no this isn't
accurate months went by without any
updates then just this weekend at London
MCM comic-con there's a banner for a
contest to win tickets to The Witcher
premiere and guess what day it's on so
it seemingly confirms that leak that
it's got to be dropping that week most
of the time Netflix drops episodes on
Fridays but there are some weeks where
they'll drop it on an off day and
because this is so close to the holidays
at the end of the year it seems like
that's what they're gonna do so I will
be doing bonus videos there's gonna be
another really big trailer that they'll
drop next weekend so of course I'll do a
video for that too
but if you have any big questions or
bonus videos for The Witcher series that
you want me to do just let me know in
the comments
everyone click here for my Easter eggs
from that last big Witcher trailer and
click here for all my Easter eggs from
the new star wars episode 9 rise of
Skywalker trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]